police in the Bahamas raised the death
toll overnight from hurricane durian to
at least 45 people hundreds are still
missing at this hour but amid the
devastation some people are refusing to
leave the only place they have ever
called home even as food and water were
scarce
Nicki batiste spoke with a few of them
at Abaco island she's now at Nassau
that's a capital of the Bahamas with
more on this story Nikki good morning to
you good morning Gail we traveled to
Abaco island yesterday expecting to see
long lines of survivors trying to
evacuate but what we found there are
still very few residents left on the
part of the island we visited and some
of them don't want to leave all of a
sudden here both the doors busted
through ninth-generation bahamian
William Malone senior says he's been
through 14 hurricanes but has never seen
loss like this he told us he survived by
hiding inside this closet as the
category 5 storm tore through I had a
comforter four pillows or me and my
girlfriend then as soon as we got in
there the bedroom roof whoop then I like
to see the sky do you think you were
gonna die yeah he then took me inside
the rest of what's left of his home of
19 years I had my pictures my family
pictures and everything and that's what
we're trying to salvage what I was
trying to salvage he says during the
hurricane water surges at least 30 feet
high swept away some of his neighbor's
so all of your family is already
evacuated but you're still here yes why
this is my home this is paradise some
density but most of the times are this
and you got to take the good with the
bad for the people that are still here
it seems there is nothing left
businesses like this store gas station
schools people's homes are completely
destroyed some of these buildings have
been searched for bodies but many people
are still missing or presumed dead as we
drove around Marsh Harbor surrounded by
we met this man and his two month old
son their home is gone so they're
seeking shelter in an abandoned house
that still has a roof no food no water
nothing are you worried about surviving
yeah a relief worker on Abaco island
told me more than a hundred children
that had been inside a school were
finally evacuated here to Nassau some
evacuees here are in shelters motels and
even private homes offered up by
complete strangers Nikki thank you